Oh
we spoil a show as always I'm your host
definition and it looks like some major
elements of Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker have made their way to the
light side of the Internet with huge
details emerging on the film's plot
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the leaks and giving my thoughts
on them there will of course be heavy
spoilers here so if you don't want to
know anything about the movie then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
leaks like this should always be taken
with a pinch of salt but these seem to
line up with other leaks that have made
their way to the net so far from
industry insiders so there's potentially
a lot here that could be in the final
film without the way I just want to give
a huge thank you for quick in this video
now let's get into my breakdown of the
rise of Skywalker okay so the film
reportedly takes place one year after
the last Jedi due to the small scale of
the rebellion after the events of the
last film the last order have managed to
conquer the galaxy the majority of the
opening takes place mostly from that
perspective but there's been some huge
change ups Hux has been replaced by
Allegiant general pride played by
Richard Lee grant and has been leaking
information to the resistance in hopes
that they kill kylo and allow him to
retake control kylo is torn between the
dark and the light side and still
harbors feelings for Rey the Knights of
Ren returned from an expedition to the
Unknown Regions to inform kylo about a
secret arsenal of super weapons built by
Palpatine kylo and the Knights of Ren
begin searching for the wayfinder a
device required to locate the Arsenal
back with the resistance we see that
they have all discovered their plan and
the group all head out to try and find
the wayfinder first Rose is now a
high-ranking resistance commander
answering directly to Leia and stays
behind to coordinate them from the base
the wayfinders coordinates are in c-3po
is old memory unit in an abandoned
Imperial blockade in a jungle world here
the heroes befriend the warrior Jana
played by Naomi Aki and her people after
retrieving it the heroes go to a
decommissioned droid factory in a snow
world to unlock it where they are
ambushed by the first order and rescued
by bounty under zouri bliss played by
Carrie Russell and her droid d0 during
the battle the memory unit of a command
droid is uploaded into c-3po causing him
to develop an aggressive personality and
take Chuy's bowcaster for himself this
kind of sounds a bit weird to me I'm not
sure how legitimate it is and it's one
of the main points of contention on the
Internet at the moment it may not be a
massive plot point but it's at this part
of the leaks that they start to really
take atone for the worse from here kylo
meets an Oracle who directs him to the
wayfinders location in a desert world
rey and her friends also learn about it
from c-3po s memories and ray and kylo
meet and fight in the desert world while
the Knights of Ren battle Finn
pochi II and the droids Rey and kylo
still share a false bond which causes
them to experience force flashes of past
events as they bite kylo in the Knights
of Ren retrieved the wayfinder and
returned to the ruins of the Death Star
in the jungle world to unlock the
Arsenal's location the resistance
follows him but they are ambushed by the
first order and nearly defeated before a
local alien cloud helps them escape
again this is another example of bad
writing in the leaks as it seems like
every situation the resistance are
pulled out of by a newly introduced
character who just appears out of the
blue which I personally think isn't that
good right from here Finn recruits Jana
and her people as reinforcements to
battle the first order while Rey
conference kylo now this is where the
leaks really take a huge turn and it's
probably the most controversial part of
the script as it deals with the return
of Palpatine Rey and kylo learn that the
wayfinder actually contains Palpatine
spirit and it's revealed that the
Knights of Ren are actually liked him
and manipulated kylo into freeing him
Palpatine possesses one of the Knights
played by Matt Smith and announces his
plans to seize control of the first
order and use the Arsenal to subjugate
the galaxy he also reveals that he was
behind Snoke so yeah a lot of retconning
here we knew that JJ Abrams wasn't too
happy with the way that his characters
had been handled in the last Jedi and
this is sort of getting stuff back on
track well I can see why people are
complaining I think it works okay as a
way to bring Palpatine back and it's
probably better than the clone stuff
that was rumored however it does bring
up the question should Palpatine even
return
to me it kind of seems like backpedaling
and sort of retro actively ruins the end
of Return of the Jedi as the character
didn't actually die
so it really negates what was one of the
most triumphant moments of the series
and now Palpatine has always been the
big bad of the saga from chronologically
the Phantom Menace all the way up to
this so I can see why they did it though
for me it just doesn't really work the
film then sort of delivers call back at
the callback as Luke Skywalker and Han
Solo appear as force ghosts and
encourage kylo to accept the light
kylo then joins forces with Rey to stop
Palpatine Rey and kylo defeat Palpatine
but he then possesses kylo kylo urges
right to kill him and she reluctantly
does and Palpatine is unable to possess
Rey and is destroyed for the last time
the first order is defeated and
Palpatine's arsenal is destroyed ramon's
kylo and luke's force ghost appears and
he resurrects him if this is true then
yeah it just doesn't work for me I think
kylo really should have a big sacrifice
and not be resurrected by a force ghost
because why has Luke not done this with
other characters it just doesn't make
sense basically and it's very
head-scratching
the film is then rumored to end with the
sunset and there were additional
comments left in the notes that discuss
a lot for the other casting
announcements
apparently Lando doesn't do that much
and isn't really integral to the plot
he's just there with the heroes
occasionally piloting things but that's
about it
the final battle will also apparently
take place on the jungle planet with a
Sith fleet there to fight they also said
that the Death Star remains will make it
to the final battle and Rey and kylo
will use force flash fights against
Palpatine and that's the entire plot
honestly it sounds a little basic to me
like some fanfiction rather than the
culmination of the trilogy that Abrams
had started out a couple of years ago
and now a lot of it will have to be a
course correction for the last Jedi but
the whole plot of we have to go
somewhere to get a weapon before the bad
guy gets there it just sounds a bit like
Leicester to me there's not really much
here that grabbed my attention and the
spirit thing seems like a really weak
way to bring Palpatine back I'm a great
believer of when a character is dead
that they're dead and whilst we have had
force ghosts in the past
they've never been able to possess
people and this seems like a bit of a
weak way to add tension and bring
characters back overall I'm hoping that
this leak isn't true as if it's not then
I really don't know if I'll feel all
that happy with the trilogy as a whole
I thought the force awakens was quite
poor and just retreading a lot about
ground the last Jedi was well the last
Jedi and this seems like another Middle
East script that Disney are putting out
just to make as much money as possible
from the property I've been really
disappointed overall with the way that
they've handled the series since taking
over it and it just seems like they're
trying to replicate the success of the
MCU without understanding that the
Marvel movies can do that because they
have a rich amount of characters that
can be brought into things whereas Star
Wars tends to have a solid cast but ones
that can't really be brought back year
after year after year and overexposed
because then they lose their magic this
reeks of ham-fisted plot devices and
underdevelopment in terms of character
Carlo becoming good just because he was
betrayed seems stupid and it comes
across like he only really turned back
to the light because he was peer
pressured into it by Han and Luke and
also realized that there wasn't really
much choice rather than him coming to
the conclusion on his own which to me
devalues the character quite a lot his
sacrifice seems rather cliche and
doesn't really make him that endearing
of a character to me now a lot of people
are saying that this is awful if true
and while I don't think it's out-and-out
horrendous there's still so much wasted
potential here that could have led to a
far better film this doesn't reach any
of the heights from Return of the Jedi
or even Revenge of the Sith and it
massively falls short for me I know they
had to finish the trilogy but it seems
kind of a poor way to say goodbye to the
characters if it's the case and I really
hope that it's not because the force is
not strong with this one
look I'm sorry yeah that's one of the
most overused jokes on the internet yeah
and I'm sorry for ending the video like
that I'm really sorry anyway and of
course love to hear your thoughts on
this plot liek what you think of it are
you excited or disappointed and it's
Star Wars done for you if this makes it
to the big screen comment below and let
me know and if you enjoyed this video
then please like it and make sure you
check out my full breakdown of the real
killers behind season 2 of mind hunter
which would be linked at the end you
want to come talk to me about movies TV
shows games and comic books and
can follow me on Twitter definition YT
it's the best way to get in touch with
me and is the perfect place to suggest
new videos and content so hopefully I
see over there after this also just want
to let you know that we're giving away a
free copy of John with Korean blu-ray
and all you have to do to be in with the
chance of winning is to like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on the
star wars leaks in the comments section
below the winner will be chosen at
random on September the 10th and the
blu-ray will be shipped out from them to
ever get surprised it's the best of luck
to everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who were mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this I've been
definition you've been the best I'll see
you next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you